comme si de rien n'était novak djokovic
s'entraîne sur les terrains de l'open
d'australie mais sa participation au
premier tournoi du grand chelem de
l'année est loin d'être garantie dans un
message adressé sur son compte instagram
le numéro 1 mondial veut clarifier sa
situation notamment concernant son
formulaire d'entrée en australie il y
affirme ne pas avoir voyagé dans les 14
jours précédant son arrivée en australie
alors qu'il était en espagne c'est la
médecine de travail qui m'envoient ce
matin le ciel est un petit problème de
vue donc on va vous tester si vous
voulez bien qu'est ce que vous lisez là
samuel approchez vous approchez
non je ne crois rien regarder novak va
faire un autre test alors c est là qu
est ce que vous lisez la
rogers va très bien bon c'est pas
terrible pour la ville et le sens de
l'essentiel c'est bien mon agent
s'excuse sincèrement pour avoir coché la
mauvaise case concernant mes anciens
voyage avant l'australie c'était une
erreur humaine qui n'était pas délibéré
nous vivons dans une époque difficile
dans le cadre d'une pandémie mondiale et
parfois ces erreurs surviennent en
australie djoko est devenu l'ennemi
public numéro un écouter ce que disent
ces journalistes qui ne pensais pas être
à l'antenne
d'autres ont choisi la catharsis comme
le dessin animé qui met les nouveaux
colis de notre monde dont 40 ans alors
mauvaise nouvelle dans 40 ans locaux
vides est toujours là mais la bonne
nouvelle c'est que dans south park les
provinces et les anti vaccins arrivent à
cohabiter peut-être que cette série cet
épisode est une pro prophétique bien sûr
on l'espère oui en effet il est en
décalage par rapport à la doxa
scientifique mais ce décalage prouve à
mon avis sera prouvée comme réel et au
cou il aura raison on lui donnera raison
dans quelques dans quelques temps vous
comprenez leur soutien à didier raoult
là je suis dit ça me brise le coeur a
coûté ils ont ils ont cru didier raoult
ils en sont morts voilà c'est ça qui
s'est passé
c'est jovial
on te dit anthony c'est pas une série
netflix a tu sais qu'en fait tu vas voir
un choc mais à la fin de la vie en fait
il ya ce qui s'appelle la mort
ça veut dire qu'il va y avoir des sièges
qui vont se libérer à quelques saisons
le turkménistan veut fermer la porte de
l'enfer c'est le surnom donné à ce
cratère gazier situé dans le désert du
karakoum devenu principal site
touristique du pays il suffit pour s'en
convaincre de voir toutes les photos
partagées sur les réseaux sociaux
voilà 50 ans que ce puits de 70 mètres
de diamètre brûle depuis qu'une
canalisation de gaz a été
accidentellement percés aujourd'hui le
président du pays veut y mettre un terme
pour des raisons sanitaires écologiques
et économiques et puis attendez c'est
important ce matin en regardant
télématin vous pourrez gagner jusqu'à 1
million de dollars comme ça waouh ouais
donc c'est pas vrai mais comme ça c'est
sûr que vous resterez tous les jours le
moment le plus stressant pour une vache
c'est le moment de la traite parce que
je sais pas si vous avez déjà assisté à
la traîne d'une vache mais ça ne se fait
plus aujourd'hui avec un pinceau et un
petit tabouret en bois posés à côté mais
entre deux barrières métalliques et avec
des ventes aux électrique qu'on va leur
coller au pis alors il ne peut pas non
plus les laisser gambader courir après
avec la très organique s'est pas
électrique un peu que sinon les
chanoines du char il est donc décidé et
bien d'essayer cette expérience
d'apposer des casques de réalité
virtuelle comme celui ci les vaches
produisent plus de méthane
quand elle pète ou quand elles roth
locale pète non quand elle rentre
et oui eh ben on va contre une idée
reçue les vaches pollue plus en rotant
camper temps et elles produisent jusqu'à
500 litres de méthane par jour un gaz
responsable du réchauffement climatique
alors oui ça peut être très drôle mais
en fait à l'arrivée c'est très dangereux
pour la planète mais elle voit quoi
justement juste avant la traite elles
vont voir ces images que vous voyez là à
l'écran c'est à dire des images de
verdure de prairies de balades en forêt
pour tenter de les détendre et ce
seulement donc les 30 minutes juste
avant la traite il a fait la teuf tests
sur deux vaches de son troupeau avec des
couleurs adapté à la vision des vaches
c'est à dire des nuances de jaune et de
bleu et ça marche ça fonctionne moins de
stress et donc plus de les manger de la
viande vous n'ont jamais c'est bien ça
mon problème passé mais non non non je
mange pas de viande mais vraiment quoi
pas par conviction par goût jeu même
quasiment qu'une viande sauf le poulet
je voudrais que le toit à toit à quoi
j'ai j'arrêterai ce que j'ai un petit
trou du coup donc j'ai trouvé du coup il
a du coup
amy jo van à giovanni alors giovanni
franchement rorschach ogrocki qu'est
née à new york sur la célèbre place de
times square parmi les publicités pour
des spectacles ou des bonbons une
affiche qui dénote un portrait géant de
molly des vices une inconnue jeune
trentenaire qui cherche l'amour et c'est
sa mère qui est à l'origine de tout
baysse d'avis 61 ans se bat contre un
cancer et n'a plus beaucoup de temps à
vivre mais avant de partir elle veut
trouver le partenaire idéal pour sa
fille vient jouer dans la ruche avoir un
garçon qui me regardent mais c'est ma
mère qui est à côté de moi qui va le lui
dire pourquoi tu crois que ça va si
baisse les yeux comme un mec quand même
un mec c'est un peu wesh wesh
à propos de votre entourage eric zemmour
qui est sarah knafou
ma collaboratrice
l'accompagnent il n'y aurait pas eu de
campagne ça s'arrête là peau autre
compagne mais on s'arrêtera là si vous
me permettez c'est la première fois vous
le dit voilà pour moi grimper l'everest
c'est le preuve d'amour et du coup je me
suis dit c'est sûr que ça va toucher les
filles mais après après faut trouver une
suite quoi ceci
pour tes citrouille non mais sérieux je
suis pas super heureux de ce que j'ai pu
créer allez un peu drôle mais elle n'est
pas romantique donc qu'est-ce que ça va
plaire aux filles je ne sais pas ces
mauvaises lors de gainage alors non non
non mais non mais non
stabilise ils peuvent y puis il doit
forcément musculaire ils auraient mal au
dos j'ai eu mal au dos je j'ai même été
au nom non my tous deux nagent chanter
j'ai décidé ça après avoir une hernie
discale qui peut arriver une opération
est pour ne plus avoir le
oui c'est vrai qu'on a l'impression que
vous avez un balai dans le dos
il s'est trouvé plus avancé bloqués sur
leur tv ses hôtes sur une fille de
cabanisation
c'est une canalisation
voilà je suis marié avec toi
bon à tout va bien ces personnes ont été
transportées dans un centre hospitalier
pour traiter je vous rassure le
professeur
là c'est sûr que oui oui là c'est un
p'tit déj en profondeur